welcome back everyone to another recap
video of the gibraltar battle of the
sexes and i actually want to start this
video by addressing
a lot of recurring youtube comments and
questions
asking
when i'm getting the gm title
and if i got any gm norms from this
tournament
in the previous video i shared my game
against grand master peer cramming in
which i won
and i also beat gm nino abatias really
earlier in the tournament so
up until this point i have defeated two
grand masters
but that doesn't mean i get a
grandmaster norm
and uh i just want to clarify maybe some
misconceptions and
educate
the
youtube viewers about what it actually
takes to get the grandmaster title
and i'll share the wikipedia page
and to get the grandmaster title you
need three norms
and you need a phoenix rating of 2500
uh currently my feed a rating is in the
2350s
and i have no grand master norms so
i'm very far away it takes a long time
to gain feed a rating especially the
higher you go the harder it is to gain
rating and to get a norm it's also very
difficult you need a performance rating
of 2 600 you need to play
at least three grand masters
in a 9 or 10 round tournament
and you need to play a mix of
federations too so your opponents have
to come from different countries and
even though there were grandmaster norm
opportunities in gibraltar
another player actually got a
grandmaster norm congratulations to
slanka from hungary uh he scored six and
a half out of ten and uh that was enough
to get a grandmaster norm
in general it's very very difficult and
it requires a lot of consistency
and uh
yeah for those asking if getting the
grandmaster title is a goal of mine
of course i want to get better at chess
it would be nice to get the gm title
sunday but realistically it's
very difficult to achieve and it would
require a lot of sacrifices on my part
i would need to travel more for
international tournaments i would have
to dedicate hours more every day of
studying
and uh
and i probably have to make less content
to just focus on getting better at chess
and i really enjoy the kind of streaming
and youtube content i'm doing these days
so i'm i'm trying to still stay
passionate about the game
and
that won't stop me from competing and
traveling and i do have tournaments
coming up that i will
i'll talk about in future videos but for
now um
i'm trying to be realistic and accept
the fact that
the gm title is still far away and it'll
take a lot of work to achieve so with
all that said i do want to share my
round 8 game from the gibraltar battle
of sexes
in this game i was playing international
master gunai mamansara
from azerbaijan
and this was a really topsy-turvy game
this was probably one of my craziest
games in the tournament
and it started with a london opening
a second time for me playing the london
in this tournament
and i decided to play it because i had
some ideas against gunai's repertoire
and actually from very early on after my
next move 95
she started taking a lot of time in the
opening and knight e5 is not the most
common move
i've given a bunch of lectures on the
london in the past and i usually
recommend bishop g3
but knight e5 is somewhat of a new trend
i started learning this move from
watching galakomsky's games
just watching his online blitz games
because he enjoys playing this move a
lot
and it offers some
very tricky and venomous lines
especially of locks not prepared so
going forward she castled played knight
t2 this is all still opening prep for me
and b6 is somewhat of a secondary move
uh the main line is c5 c3
knight to c6 bishop d3 queen c7 and i
would have played knight f3 here and
this is sort of the main tavia position
most common move is 94.
um just to illustrate one potential trap
if knight d7
which looks very natural to try and just
target the nylon e5
uh white is already almost winning with
the move knight g5 and if you're curious
to analyze this further
uh the engine will kind of share the the
best vest variations but the attack on
the king side is very overwhelming and
after knight f6 back to defend there's
knight g4
and white is uh having a very powerful
attack
so going back b6 it's um
slightly a less confrontational move
but it does give white time to
get kind of an interesting setup
and the move i played here is pawn h4
which if i check in the masters database
this move has only been played twice
before
uh once actually by andrew tang
and h4 is actually the engine's top
recommendation
according to stockfish 14.
so it's kind of a new
engine inspired way of playing
where
white just wants to gain space on the
king's side
and create scenarios where it'll be
easier to attack in the middle game
and i'm also delaying developing lights
for bishop in the vent of bishop to a6 i
can take it immediately
if i play bishop d3 first and then
bishop a6 i might lose a tempo if i
decide to take in this position
so played h4
this should be seven
and queen f3
so
maybe not the typical setup in the
london usually the knight goes to f3 but
with the queen on f3 it enables for the
eventual queen g3
to reinforce e5 and also online with the
king and here she played somewhat of a
surprising move
knight to c6
um almost always if black plays knight
c6 it's
after
black has already played c5 and uh looks
a little bit awkward to
put the knight in front of the c pawn
but it was played with some interesting
intention uh for example if i play
bishop d3 then she can play
knight b4 and probably force a trade of
some minor pieces
and there's another idea here of playing
like e7 uh just to reroute and then
eventually play c5
uh so i decided to play h5 here just
gain space uh threatening h6 which i
think is a positional threat so she
played h6 herself
i played c3 restricting the knight on c6
and she played king h8
so up until this point uh she'd already
used a lot of time
and i was feeling quite comfortable um
have a nice grip in the center
and king is a sign that maybe it's not
entirely clear what black is trying to
accomplish in this position
so i went ahead complete development
bishop d3
and then after the trade on e5 takes
takes
knight d7
uh it's looking really good for white
because i just got the bishop hair and
now i have a pawn in e5 which i do
defend with queen g3
and during the game i thought i was much
much better
but
it turns out that black
does have counter play here and she was
actually really resourceful
with uh the next few moves
starting with knight c5 grabbing
initiative by hitting the bishop
and after i retreated she plays really
nice move bishop to a6
where this basically turns one of her
worst pieces into one of her best pieces
now the bishop that pierces through the
diagonal prevents me from casting
kingside but also targets the d3 square
which is
a bit of a weakness in my position
now i have to worry about bishop d3 or
knight d3
and here it's looking very likely i'm
going to have to trade off
my light squared bishop which is one of
the potential attackers against the side
so i thought for a bit here and decided
that i'm best just casting queen side
and trying to create a sharp game
um getting my rook to the center
so she continued here with bishop to d3
uh offering the trade and i didn't want
to take immediately which would allow
takes king b1 and then
knight takes f4 and i think the the more
things that are traded the more
comfortable black becomes
just with the space deficit
so rather than taking on d3 i left the
tension
and played what i thought was kind of an
interesting move is queen to h2
even though it looks a little bit
strange the idea is to make way for the
g pawn
and one of the ways white
can try to just attack ruthlessly and
open up the king side
is with the eventual pawn g5 break
to open up the g file and if i can get
rid of the h pawn then maybe my h pawn
can advance
so my intentions were very clear here
and here she played a very timely move
pawn to f6
which does a lot of useful things for
black
aims to get rid of my e5 pawn and even
though it looks a little bit weakening
to the g5 square black does want to open
that file and create counter play
maybe at first it looks like i can win
the c7 pawn if it takes
and takes and
bishop takes c7
but this would just lose f2 and it would
just be a very bad transformation for
white
so after she played f6 i played the move
knight to f3
attempting to reinforce e5 and also uh
unleash the rook to attack the bishop
we trade on c2 and then trade on e5 and
now i have to take with the bishop on e5
if i take with the knight then this
would lose f2 after takes takes and
takes
so trying to hold my ground and after it
takes i take with the queen on e5
after the dust has settled a little bit
it turns out that black is actually
completely fine here and i don't really
have
much of an attack on the king's side
uh she hits my queen with rook f5
i move back
and then knight e4
black actually has a good grip on the
position and black is almost certainly
the one for choice here
and during the game i was still
optimistic because i did have a pretty
substantial time advantage
uh we're on move 21 and i believe she
was already below 10 minutes at this
point
just having spent so much time in the
opening
and uh okay the game continues from here
i play rook hf1 defending the f pawn
she plays c5 and then i play knight to
e5
so trying to make use of my knight uh e5
is a very nice square and i'm now eyeing
the g6 square so she plays queen e8
uh hitting h5
i play g4 hitting the rook and defending
h5
and now queen a4 check which uh i guess
was another point of queen e8
and turns out the queen is a little bit
annoying here because the move i would
like to play is king to b1
but this would leave my rook a bit
vulnerable and now my work on f1 is
overworked because it's defending d1
and it's defending f2
and i can just take on f2 here and i
can't take back with rook because i get
mated
and this is actually completely losing
for white because my queen is hit and
black hasn't made into threat as well
so
after queen a4
i didn't see this coming and i played
the move king to c1
which is not the greatest square for the
king but it does keep the recovered and
black doesn't have time to take on a2
because her rook is still hit on f5 so
she played rook f6 i play f3
knight g5
and then i play f4
and i thought things were very much
going in my favor here um just getting
initiative against knight
and then she played a move which i had
completely overlooked
and already at this point i think she
was below a minute
but uh
after the next move i realized that
the position is uh is quite complicated
it turns out the knight doesn't have to
move here
and black can go ahead and take on a2
and the problem for white is i can't
immediately take on g5 because after
takes takes queen a1 check uh white is
the one just losing material
so going back
queen takes a2 is very resourceful and i
just have to find a different option
rather than taking the knight
and i decided to play king c2 here which
gets my king off the first rank and now
does have the threat of taking the
knight
and even though i'm down upon here the
black 1a2 i i was still feeling
optimistic because i have this nice kind
of pawn swarm on the king side and i
thought there's a good attacking
potential
but after queen a4 king b1
e4
black also has good attacking potential
and things can get very sharp and
dangerous if i'm not careful
uh so i play rook g1 here
trying to prepare the g5 break
she plays queen b3 and unfortunately
black is the first one to start throwing
punches here because now there's a
lethal threat of knight take c3
and there's not too many ways for white
to defend
uh so the move i played is queen c2
just trying to neutralize and trade
queens and then still try and attack on
the king's side
in hindsight maybe i should have played
rook c1 which would have left queens on
the board and made things uh just more
sharp and interesting
but i played queen c2
and we traded queens
and after pawn c4
rook a1 i'm down upon but uh there's
still kind of the element of time
trouble
and i was hopeful to get some setup with
rook a6 and then rook a1 to
pressure lax queen's eye pawns
but she played a nice move here knight
c5 just covering the squares on the
queen side
also targeting some weak light squares
in my position
and here i played g5 trying to break
through on the king's side takes takes
and here's where she made a clear
mistake in time trouble
uh play the move which tried to simplify
but it turned out to simplify in my
favor
i was rooked to f5
black should have played 94 just to
chase my rook away
and
just kind of keep the position stable
but the problem with rook f5
is i was very happy to take
and after e takes i5
play the move rook to d1
and it turns out that i'm winning back
the pawn because there's not a great way
for black to keep the d5 pawn defended
i've ripped a here and then i have a
very simple fork
now momentum is beginning to shift
back in my favor
uh she played the move knight d3 which
is an attempt to uh just try and
simplify even further but after knight
takes d3 cd3 rook d3
i won back the pawn and i'm still
threatening the d5 pawn so she plays
rook to d8
and now i play the move c4 and it looks
like i'm gonna win the pawn because
there's a pin how does that defend but
then she has to move rook to c8
uh with the counter pin and counter
attack now it's my pawn who's attacked
twice
uh so we actually end up trading pawns
but after takes and takes
we're very quickly simplifying uh deep
into a rook ending
uh i play king d3
rook b4
and at this point we've passed mu 40 we
each got extra half hour
and at first
it looks like the position is just
heading towards the draw because
it's currently equal material it's
looking for
versus working for
uh looks like we're about to trade f5
for b2
and the move i
initially wanted to play here was king
c3
to defend and attack
then black has rookie 4 and e3 would be
hanging and i probably have to just
repeat
so rather than going into
any sort of repetition with keen c3
i realized that
i can take on f5
and if black takes on b2
now it's rook in 3 versus rook and 3
but it's white who has very very good
winning chances here because after rook
f8 king h7 e4
this pawn is ready to just bolt down the
board
and black is just really stuck on the
king side um can't play king h6 because
rook h a checkmate
and if g6 and i can play rook f7
king h6 takes takes and takes this would
be a winning end game for white
so long story short
we got to this position i took on f5
and then she started thinking for a
while because
she made the realization that rook takes
b2
it just leads to a position which looks
completely winning for white so she
ended up playing rook b3 check first
to try and make my king decide where it
wants to go
i play king d4
and then she played king g8
ensuring that i don't have rook f8 and
the king will be closer to the center
in the event that my e pawn starts
advancing
the drawback of king g8 is i have a nice
move rook to g5 which i played
and this move has two purposes
uh first of all i am intending to
potentially go back to g2 and just
defend the pawn
but i'm also having a tactical thread of
h6 here
and there's not enough time for black to
really address everything that i want to
do
and she played king f7 and then i have
time for g2 and now it's white just
playing for a win because i have
an extra pawn and i also have the only
pass pawn on the board
um so i was feeling very very good here
and if we just go forward a few moves
rook b5 was played play rook h2 king e7
and then i simplified down with pawn h6
forcing a trade
and even though i do lose b2
i have rook h7
king d6 and rook takes a7 and here we
reach a
pretty
well known type of
rook ending where white has two
connected past pawns
black has one pass pawn
and i knew during the game that this
should be
a pretty straightforward window for
white but as we're gonna see it still
takes some technique to get the job done
and she started with rook f2 which is a
nice move it does paralyze both my pawns
because i can't play f5 and e4 would
lose f4
so i start here with rook h7 she plays
rook d2
i play king e4
pawn b5
rook b7 rook b2
and here we reach a critical moment
and i'll say right now that it does pain
me to
look back at this position
because there's so many different ways
for white to win here
and i managed to find
one of the only moves
that makes a position drawn
and even though this is really painful
to look back on especially with the the
move i played next
it does offer a really valuable lesson
and it shows
what i need to work on if i want to
reach the next level and maybe chase a
gm title someday
i really need to be more precise and
robust with my end games
and when i get a winning advantage i
really really have to stay focused and
not get too relaxed
in the midst of a game
and i think the other thing to address
here
is
we played four hours of chess to get to
this position
and at this point
i was physically and mentally
very tired
and
it clearly had an impact on my play
and if i really want to improve my game
and play at a higher level
i have to work on my my physical and
mental stamina have to put more priority
in exercising sleeping well
diet
because sometimes it's uh the external
factors that can make a big impact on
your form in in situations like this so
let me show the the move that i played
is uh is pawn to f5
and in the moment i thought this is a
reasonable move because my simple plan
is king f4
and start advancing my pawns but her
next move completely escaped me uh the
move rook before check
and for some reason when i played f5 i
just this this move uh did not cross my
mind because all i was thinking was
either b4 or king c6 is coming but of
course i should anticipate a move like
this
and the problem is after rook b4
my king has to move back
i played king f3 and this allows the
black king to come into e5
and from here the game was still a fight
and i'll share the finish to the game in
just a moment
but just to show what i should have done
here
is play the move king f5 and i'm pretty
sure i consider this move but i was just
way too relaxed i thought everything was
winning
and i don't think i played this because
i was scared of like king c6 rook ba
king c7 my rook would have had to leave
the b-file
but
this is still a winning position for
white because once the king is in front
of the past pawns it can more easily
guide them up the board
and meanwhile my rook can just come back
and prevent the b-pawn from promoting
so um i should have gone for this
position but
can't undo the past
i played pawn f5 allowing rook b4 and
it's really unfortunate because after
king e5
i played the move e4
i'm very close
to keeping my pawns defended and
connected
uh black can't take on e4 with a rook
because i take on b5 and this is winning
for white
but
black has to move rook b3 here
and after king g4
king takes e4
it turns into a pawn race
which even though i'm slightly ahead in
advancing my pawn black is just in time
to hold the draw we see what happened
the game played pawn f6
rook b1
king g5 this point it doesn't make a
difference if uh if i do play f7 then
black would just defend and uh probably
transpose into what happened in the game
so play king g5
and now really nice move from black king
d4
just getting the king to help the b-pawn
advance
and the rook is just about ready to come
to f1
to uh defend against my f pawn from
promoting and the move i want to play
here is pont f7
but after rook f1
king g6 king c4 king g7
will enter a situation where yes i do
promote and make a queen and win the
rook but unfortunately my king is just
too far away and this is a pretty
typical endgame scenario
where black is uh
is gonna
basically force me to sack the rook for
the pawn or for some sort of perpetual
so rather than going for this line i
decided to play rook h7 in this position
and the point of this move was to be a
little bit clever and have the idea of
rook h4 and rook f4
to deal with the rook f1 idea
but unfortunately black uh starts at the
move rook to g1
after king f5 rook f1
i don't really have time to get my rook
to f4
and after king e6
b4 i began to accept the reality that
this end game is just to draw and i
missed my uh my opportunity
to win earlier and
yeah the game ended
with some repetition
um really not much else to do here um so
it was a bit of a painful game given
that i worked so hard to kill a winning
endgame and then spoiled it with one
move
uh this pawn f5 move
but um game like this it uh i think it
can happen to everyone it's one of the
brutal things of chess
is you you build up a winning advantage
uh for several hours and
all it takes is one
blunder
to give away the advantage so i hope
this offers some lesson to uh to the
viewers
um i hope you guys learned a thing or
two it was a fun game um looking back
there were a lot of a lot of takeaways
in the opening middle game especially
end game so if you have any comments or
questions leave them below
and i look forward to seeing you in the
next video